[Music]
[Applause]
tom brady's partnership with hertz
continues this spring a series of
engaging ads social content this time
around hertz and tom are getting
customers to
their let's go moments featuring
alongside tom and the ads the new hertz
exclusive shelby mustangs the newest
addition to hertz ev rental fleet we
spoke to tom yesterday spent some time
we were allowed 10 minutes we went a
little bit longer and i started with the
question
if you would have stuck with baseball he
was drafted by the montreal expos if he
had stuck with baseball instead of
football where would you be today
i'd be selling insurance baseball was
not my sport
i loved it but i was much it turned out
to be obviously
football was the one i chose for a
reason
uh although i did love baseball it was a
great sport growing especially in
california growing up barry bonds went
to my high school
greg jeffries
um
some it was a great baseball school so
that was my
first first love and then football
obviously once i started playing
football was game over okay but what's
the scouting report on tom brady
baseball player
uh a lot like football you know probably
not that powerful uh you know
pretty smart game manager
[Laughter]
not very fast on the first baseline okay
probably best at catcher where he
doesn't have to move that much but likes
to direct other people around so
i think
probably wouldn't be much different i
think you've come full circle from the
picture at the combine to now you and
your underwear selling tom brady
underwear
it all worked out yeah
yeah
somehow it worked out i know a lot of a
lot of time in the last 23 years to get
a little bit better shape so i was a
college kid i was coming out of college
oh my god that probably wasn't my finest
moment but i always joke about that
picture like no one else has a picture
like that where's peyton manning's
picture
uh he didn't look great in those in
those gray shorts either so but i just
somehow never see a picture of that what
would you pay to have that picture
from the combine and you remove it from
civilization
oh man
you know what i wouldn't pay anything uh
but i would just uh
it serves as a great reminder where i've
come from so at this part at this point
i would say it's i'm pretty cool with it
it's i look back and i think god i
remember that day i remember
rooming with mark bulger
in
an indianapolis hotel room
and laughing you know about where we
were at and couldn't imagine that we
were both in this position we were in
that you know
brady bulger wasn't the greatest
quarterback class chris redman and chad
pennington
so uh we've come a long way since then
but mark actually had a great career tim
retay
um
a lot of these guys said just i don't
run into that much anymore but
we had a good we had a great time i love
that you remember all the quarterbacks
that were taken ahead of you though
a few that were taken after two t martin
geocarmazi i remember all them but that
that was really important to me at the
time i mean it was my whole life i was
that was the beginning of the internet
where they were doing mock drafts you
know and you went on these
these sites and you saw you know where
this person thought you were going to
draft it where this person thought you
would get drafted so it was it was a lot
going into that
um
you know that year
and uh it seems like it went so fast
literally i blinked my eye i'm like here
i am i'm like holy
where did the time go
and you know i can't believe that
you know i played this long it's hard to
imagine i know you're uh representing
hertz if i said you could have three
teammates
get in the rental car with you
and you're gonna start a new team
any three all time who who's in the the
back seat
or maybe one's in the front seat with
you
guys i've played with you guys that i
played against
i'll let you pick
three guys
he's gonna start a football team
i would say that's
there's more than three so i think that
there's a there's reasons why all of
them would be there and not for the
reasons that people may see
um
and i don't think just three would be
would be would be right
there would probably be ten
um
does hertz have an suv that we can put
ten guys in they must have a 15 seater
okay i gotta get like a 15
kind that my neighbors had when you know
they had nine kids next door and they
had the minivan or the large van
rodney harrison was great
[Music]
wes welker was great
randy moss
um
i mean there's too many to name ty law
um kevin faulk
julian edelman gronk
i'm
well you got ty and rodney in there so
like ty and ryami um i mean they're all
everyone's everyone's
different for different reasons i think
about all our great teams
everyone
some some years our defense was a little
bit better than offense so when i think
about those years like richard seymour i
mean he's unbelievable vince wilfork um
junior seau
um asante samuel
and then you know other years our
offense was totally dynamic like oh
seven when you're thinking about more
wes and randy kevin faulk
so
matt light and everyone was so good they
were all great i mean for god's sakes
they're in the nfl they're one of the
greatest
you know in the world so
you know i almost said it's
i almost said this to you on the podium
when you guys beat seattle
and it probably wasn't going to be fair
to you but i almost said to you
do you think you should give the keys to
malcolm butler
yeah
that truck when did you decide that you
were going to do that
you know i will say
that that was one of the greatest
defensive plays in the history of the
nfl
um
malcolm butler had that ability to make
that play there are very very few
cornerbacks in the nfl that have the
twitchiness
and the reaction to get to that football
and as much as people will say oh you
should have handled the ball off we put
a defense in that day that didn't allow
you to hand the ball off
um you know they you know there's kind
of a
a clip on our sideline where they call
like goal line three corners malcolm ran
in
we forced them to throw the ball
and you know they could have given it to
marshawn obviously i would say that
you know the coverage was an all-out
blitz and the ball had to come out quick
and malcolm made the play so i do think
that was one of the great plays in nfl
history that malcolm you know for his
great for i would say as much reaction
to oh they should have handed the ball
off i wish there was the same reaction
that was can you believe how incredible
of a play that was that malcolm made in
fact that's why i gave malcolm the car
because malcolm deserved the car
and uh you know i think he still got it
how involved were you with the uh the
concept of these commercials with hertz
pretty involved you know i i
you know i absolutely saw them from kind
of inception they were a lot of fun you
know i think the part of them we're just
trying to show
we're also you know deadly serious with
everything we talk about these days you
know trying to have fun with different
things i mean
we all could laugh a little bit more so
i love the fact that even with social
media
at least that what i try to do is just
lighten people's mood a little bit have
a little fun with the day you know not
take things too seriously and i think
these hurt ads all reflect kind of a
little bit of that so
uh
i've had two production days with them
we got another one coming up but they've
been really fun to work with
um
you know the the group of the leadership
group at hertz has done a great job it's
really a great brand and they're doing
great things with their business and
transitioning most of their fleet to
um
evs electric vehicles with i think they
had put in the largest tesla order uh in
the world or something so part of elon
getting to a trillion dollar wealth or
something is going to be this this hurts
order so good for him
give me the day the moment when you say
to giselle
i'm going back
uh you know we had quite a bit of time
together um
i think mostly when i
kind of told the team look like you know
you guys got to make plans without me
you know and then you know jason and
bruce said just give it time you know
and i said look i i feel pretty strongly
you know and
and then you know time went by and then
you just get super competitive you know
and
i think i'm part crazy i mean i think
that's the reality i mean
45 years old and i'm out here with
a lot of young guys that are trying to
take my head off and i see aaron donald
work out on my instagram like damn maybe
i should have retired
you know
because he's a beast
but you know i had the appetite to
compete and uh
it's gonna be gone soon i mean there's
no doubt about it and i gotta
you know just really appreciate what the
time i have left because it's not a lot
but i wonder the transition
and and you know drew brees went through
this like you get done and then he went
into the studio and that's too abrupt
like that's that that's that's a
different reality you're going from
playing to preparing for a game in a
different way while you're at the site
you're gonna feel that energy i mean
that's as close as you're going to get
to playing again it feels like or i
don't know if that factored in with you
wanting to be game site as opposed to
studio
yeah and i think that's what i because
i'm most familiar with that
um just based on the fact that i've
look i've been in every production
meeting for 22 years you know since that
when i started playing in 2001
um
i know what those guys are asking i know
what they're asked to do
[Music]
and i think it feels very much like a
team that goes on the road to prepare
for a game so there's a lot of learning
curve i mean obviously
it's a it'll be a totally new career
it's a new opportunity for me to try
something that i'm gonna work really
hard to prepare to be as as good as i
possibly can be knowing that the day
that i walk on the set for the first
time won't be my finest moment there'll
be
you know a lot of growing pains and i'll
have to learn to be really good at it
but i also think there's part of it that
excites me is i get to travel
and be around football and be around
people that
um
you know i've i've been around great
mentors in my football career you know
being blessed to get drafted by the
patriots i was around one of the great
owners in the history of the nfl and mr
kraft one of the great
the greatest head coach in nfl history
in uh you know in coach belichick josh
mcdaniels charlie weiss romeo cornell i
mean the list goes on with the coaches
that i've been around general managers
jason light scott pioli
i get to be around players
you know i had the best players you know
i was around best defensive players
offensive players
um you know i've been covered by by john
madden you know i've been at super bowl
media days i just i've had so much
experience and
if i can help people along the way you
know uh by my travels and by talking to
coaches and talking to players you know
i've i love the sport of football and
i've um
you know i get to be in it so i think
that's what mostly i got excited about
and i think part of retiring for a very
brief period of time was i got to
explore a lot of other opportunities
um and things that just came up that
and this and this is the one that i
really excited me the most so
um
you know it in the end although it was
kind of
abrupt it ended up being very
i'm happy i went through it how long
would it take you to find a super bowl
ring
in the house
uh i just need a key to my safe and i've
got i got it that's it so uh i know i
know where they're at although they
don't come out very often but i do know
where they're at never too far away hey
congrats good to talk to you thanks for
uh sharing some time
thanks dan take care pal have a great
summer
tom brady joining us on behalf of hertz
of course tb12 and we went 12 minutes we
were supposed to go 10 minutes energy
yes
have a great summer pal
see at the beach